alors attention on va y aller crescendo
d'accord attention qu'il était prête à
chypre est c'est parti
merci bien pour toi je sois un point
dans compris merci
maintenant si je gagne le premier point
c'est gagné ouais bah oui on n'a pas
grand-chose à l'effort a par contre les
forts bon allez vas-y fais ton de l'ema
oui la pauvre voilà merci kenny on peut
l'appeler promettre par or merci merci
meilleur donc après après le plus le
faire c'est maxime qui n est pas bon
ah ouais c'est un coup prodigieux gerbe
au ping pong un bon sens et pas est-ce
que ce ne serait ce que fait le service
non mais non mr des envies si les
enfants c'est que j'ai ça merlus
allaient si tu peux merci on a que je
vous le dis on n'a qu'une balle c'est
bernard
[Applaudissements]
à
amis jouent bien celui-ci regarde comme
il prend ses arrières nadine bolli tu
joues parade et bronze en fait permis d
ailleurs si bernard tu vas là-bas ouais
bah moi single attention valéry mézague
aller bâle paris banlieue y aller petit
poucet le concept
[Applaudissements]
une triche la divinité merci merci
accusant michel mais attention dans son
épuisette pour l'instant mon chéri ça se
passe vers 1
ça se passe bien j'ai ri et pourquoi et
super g à monter j'ai à présent voter la
connerie entre twilight était géniale
jour au nom de mercy gens vibrent aux
laiteries kerimov si l'on me bat là-bas
par la station isabelle alida à lisa
ayasse herald il maniait l'enlever
chaussures et ou à la faune pour
l'instant jérémy tu gagnes un témoignage
fait glisser les dieux merci simple un
vase image est bien engagée bonjour non
vous êtes là bas typhi obligé à y
résister même sa fin que c'est arrivé
à j'engage engage au calme toi quand
même ses proches et vous n'avez pas
l'habitude de jouer sur le nom long trop
long et minutieux la main trop long ce
avec le plus fort entre banques a évolué
que c'est qui est qu'il peut fort c'est
un bon temps les deux éditions la vie
est toujours jean luc là je vous le dis
ça se corse benjamin ça se corse à les
belges gérer mes potes
[Applaudissements]
vas-y champions sont des potes sont nés
pour le match allait consentante wha
kang wannian téléviseur et l'autre le
dioula téléviseur en place télévision
impose aux states
[Musique]
mais attention quand on gagne avec
dukurs vous tirez a touché la pochette
bien sûr quatre touches regarde les
jours regarder sur la mais oui pas ça ne
s'est pas vu craint lui que si c'était
fait exprès en plus est quand même au
poste de télévision
djelic alors tu fais exprès petit bras
allez-y chef
[Applaudissements]
non
les cartes
[Applaudissements]
jerry rice jérémy ça va se jouer
maintenant combien trois points gagnants
une belle d'échauffement en gagnant
quatre points gagnants sont en fait on
va faire du ping pong que toutes les
missions je suis je suis venu pour ça
valait notre à greta nous c'est beaucoup
plus facile
malheureux
ces partis n'avaient personne qu'après
j'ai quoi vous avez peur c'est
l'échauffement nombre de balles
d'échauffement intervient en cinq
soirées crêpes en cinq mois c'est parti
ça rebondit pas j'ai fait craindre que
le cas soit on a compris c'est l'égalité
oui
ça rigole pas là alors j'apporte mon nom
je t'avoue sinon ça bien avant toi
[Applaudissements]
tu es fou tu as déjà sauvé trois balles
de match pop rock sans aa
[Rires]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
ses rivaux
via la vie
prochain ensuite avec l'écran plus eu
part en voyage au chili pour le bloc de
l'os
[Applaudissements]